Welcome to this toxic Google
events in our Seattle office.
I have to admit that
since I was a little girl,
I've been fascinated by space and stars
and planets and the universe and so it
gives me a great pleasure to
introduce today's speaker.
David Sobel is a former New York Times
science reporter and he repeated New York
Times bestselling author.
Her previous books include longitude
about the English clockmaker,
John Harrison and gala was daughter
about gallows older daughter,
Maria Celeste and planets,
which I'm sure you can guess is about
earth and her nearest neighbors.
She's a recipient of the National
Science Board's Individual Public Service
Award, the Boston Museum of
Science Bradford Washburn Award.
And she even has an asteroid
named after her. Please.
Let's welcome David Sobel.
Thank you.
Thank you very much. Okay, thank you.
So I'm going to talk today about a
group of women who worked at the Harvard
Observatory starting in
the 1880 [inaudible]. And
the women in this picture,
I don't have a whole lot
to do with that story.
They're kind of the granddaughters
of the original group.
Um, but the, the woman who's
picture is over the word glass,
that is Wendy Freedman,
who was a head of the Carnegie
observatories in Pasadena for years now.
She's at University of Chicago.
And she gave me the idea for
this book about 20 years ago.
She was the head of a Hubble telescope
key project about the expansion rate of
the universe.
And she mentioned the name
Henrietta 11 it to me.
And I had never heard of hand.
We had 11.
And then when I went to
learn more about her,
turned out she was working in a
whole room full of women at Harvard.
And, um, that was surprising any,
any large number of women
anywhere at Harvard. Um,
but the Harvard Observatory where they
worked was really separate from the
university and there had always been
women working there and because several of
the astronomers just lived at the
observatory, so their wives, sisters,
daughters got roped into doing
whatever needed to be done.
And there was a lot of computing work.
So this was an era when computer
was a job description and,
um, a lot of what they
were looking at, uh,
were stellar positions.
That's mostly what astronomy
was about in the 19th century.
Mapping the stars,
figuring out positions,
and then the computers would have
make corrections for the atmospheric
distortion for the Earth's
motion in space, uh,
procession. So there was,
was a lot of computing to do.
And then in 1877,
a very young physicist, Edward
Pickering, he was 29 years old,
uh,
took over as director
of the observatory.
And there was a lot of question about
whether he was the right person for this
because he was a physicist,
not an astronomer.
And he immediately got interested in
doing projects that would uncover the
physics of the stars. He wasn't as
interested in just the position work.
He had to do that.
But he introduced other things as well
and he'd been teaching at MIT where he
set up a laboratory so the physics
students could learn things for themselves
through experiments that
he, he, uh, set up for them.
And a,
this is what the building looked like
in the early days was a wooden building
and there was, there were two
telescopes and then the directors,
residents was the part without the dome.
And uh,
one of the Pickerings first projects
was to try to determine the different
brightnesses of,
of the various stars.
So this was the main
instrument at the observatory.
This is a 15 inch telescope that was
a gift from the people of Boston.
And there's bickering in the chair. I
mean, I don't know if it's really him,
but somebody who's somebody is
sitting there. So to do this work,
the brightness Worki had to build his
own photometers and at first he attached
them to this instrument,
but later,
later they got more complex and had
their own telescopes attached to them.
And he was very interested in photography.
His younger brother was
a photography pioneer,
was also at MIT. And uh, this man,
this is Dr. Henry draper who was a
medical doctor but was a real pioneer in
stellar photography.
And not just taking
pictures of star scapes,
but using prisms to split
the star light into Spectra.
And then photographing the spectrum.
And he was the only person who
was able to do that at the time.
And the, uh, the lady
there is his wife and uh,
they work together.
Um,
she became his full time assistant
and because he was an amateur,
he was free to do this unusual new
work that was not being done at other
observatories.
And because she was independently wealthy,
he could afford to build instruments,
take whatever time he needed.
And they were planning
to leave New York City,
they had a townhouse in New York City,
um,
but the had an observatory,
uh,
up the Hudson River and they were going
to go devote themselves full time to
this project of photographing stellar
spectrum and then figuring out a
classification system for the stars
based on differences in the spectrum.
And they had all their
affairs in order to do this.
And then he suddenly died.
He was 45 and she really
wanted to continue the work.
She thought she might get some assistance
to fill in her husband's knowledge and
work with her,
but it turned out to be difficult.
And so she offered Pickering the money
to do the work if he would just take over
this dream project.
And she wanted him to promise that
he would name it after her husband.
So it became the Henry Draper Memorial.
And uh,
so this is a textbook image of a spectrum.
That's what people usually think
of the rainbow and the, the um,
absorption lines.
Uh,
but of course there was
no color photography yet.
So the images look like this.
The enlarged images look like this.
Um,
Pickering's photographs look
like this mostly because,
uh, instead of putting the
spectroscope at the eye piece,
it was putting the prison, I'll be the
light gathering end of the telescope.
So he was getting hundreds
of spectrum in each image.
And um,
so the job was to look at those tiny
smears through a magnifying glass and then
come up with a system for classifying
the stars. The black spot is a penny.
And so with all this money,
it misses Draper's money was the equal
of the entire operating budget of the
observatory.
So Pickering was free to hire more women.
He had found women working there when he
arrived and they were good at what they
did and they were less expensive than men.
It's an old story.
It's still true in a lot
of places. Um, so, uh,
this is, this is what the
computing room looked like.
Uh,
this woman will you meet a Fleming had
come to the observatory to work as a
maid.
She found herself suddenly
unmarried and pregnant and uh,
just applied for this job.
And then Pickering noticed how
intelligent she was and moved her into the
observatory,
uh,
where she learned how to do computations
and also how to look at photographs.
And she went home to have her baby,
but he promised her home to Scotland.
She was a Scottish immigrant and he
promised her real job if she would come
back. And she did. And um,
she made the first Henry Draper
classification of 10,000 stars,
which was published and
she was credited for it.
And then she became the first woman
to have a university title at Harvard.
She was the curator of
astronomical photographs.
She also managed to bring the baby over
and put him through school at Mit and he
became a mining engineer.
The very formidable looking woman at
the telescope here is Mariah Mitchell,
who was the first American woman who
really became famous as an astronomer
because she discovered a comet in 1847.
And the young woman and Tonia
Maury was Henry Drape was nice.
And um,
she went to Vassar college where Mariah
Mitchell was professor of astronomy.
So when Antonio Maury came to
work at Harvard on this project,
she had a very good background in
astronomy and she developed her own seller
classification system, which was much
more complicated than Mrs Fleming's.
Um, so for a while there
were two systems and uh,
it took a third person to
balance out that,
uh,
situation and create something in the
middle that was so effective that it's
still in use today.
And this is Annie jump cannon.
Uh, she was a graduate of
Wellesley College. So the,
these new women's colleges became feeder
schools to the project and Harvard.
And there was a lot of
controversy at the time,
whether higher education
was good for women. Uh,
there was even a feeling that college
was actually bad for girls and that it
would negatively affect their
ability to bear children.
I couldn't make that up. Um, uh,
but Pickering was all for it.
And not only was he hiring women,
but he was appealing directly to the
alumnae of these colleges and saying,
you know, if you've studied
astronomy, if you have a telescope,
there are observations we need to have
made and you could contribute to the
work. And he got a lot
of takers for that. Um,
Ms. Cannon was the first woman at the
observatory who was not just looking at
photographic plates,
but making her own observations.
So the,
uh,
the painting of her at the telescope is
from a children's book called Annie Jump,
cannon astronomer by,
um,
Carol Gerber and the illustrations
invite Christina Waltz.
So here's what it,
Ms Canon's plates.
MMM.
It's not for everyone.
Okay.
And, uh, these are Ms Canon's diaries.
One of my concerns when I
took on this project was,
um,
would I be able to make the women come
real in the story or were they just going
to sound like one lady nerd
after another? And, uh,
fortunately the archival material was
rich and 40 years of Ms Canon's diaries.
I probably know her better than
I know some of my friends. And,
um, uh, this is thrilling
kind of work to do.
I don't know if any of you've ever had
this experience of going to an archive,
but it's just,
um,
it always surprises me how
much is available just by
virtue of being interested
in a subject.
This is
so just there for the asking.
So,
uh,
for,
in order for Pickering to create a
complete record of the night sky,
which was what he wanted to do,
he had to have an observatory
in the southern hemisphere
as well as the northern
hemisphere. And he sent this
ban. So when Bailey to, uh,
recognize order sites in South
America where they could, uh,
carry on the work too, and this
was their, their first spot,
uh,
they called this Mount Harvard,
very rustic.
And then they built a more permanent
installation near the town of Eric Keeper
in Peru in the Lee of a dormant volcano.
It'll misty and later it turned
out it wasn't so dormant, uh,
but they were there, uh, and
for the southern hemisphere,
Pickering wanted a new kind of telescope,
which he designed specifically
for photography, uh,
and one that would take enormous plates.
These were 11 inches by 17 inches.
And once again,
an interested Eris stepped forward,
wrote him a check for $50,000
to build this telescope,
which has her name. Her name
was Catherine Wolfe, Bruce.
And, uh, she also, uh,
in Dowd astronomers
everywhere, she set up a, uh,
a grant pool.
And if you had a proposal,
you could send it to her and Pickering
would do all the judging and she'd send
you some money.
Um,
and she was also approached
by the Astronomical Society
of the Pacific to endow
a lifetime achievement
award for astronomers.
And it remains a very prestigious
prize today. The Bruce Metal.
Uh, so life in Peru wasn't all, uh, uh,
fighting Scorpions and staying up all
night. They had picnics sometimes.
And, uh, this, this lady,
I'm not getting this to work.
There she is. That's Mrs. Bailey.
Ruth Poulter Bailey.
And she helped him in the work.
She did the meteorology observations
and she also helped in his studies.
He was especially interested
in globular clusters. Uh,
the dark skies in South America
really made these pop and he,
he was fascinated to see how many variable
stars there were in these clusters.
So even with the close up,
you can imagine the job it was to
count the stars in these images.
Uh, and, but when you got to the middle,
it was, it was really mission impossible.
Uh, Henry at 11, the first
name I learned of these women,
uh,
she was given plates from the
Bruce Telescope to discover
as many variable stars
as possible.
And so that meant not only
looking at the images but,
but then looking at them over time.
So you assess the brightness in one image,
but then you keep assessing it as
you look at subsequent photographs.
And, uh, and this is the
small Magellanic cloud,
which is not visible at all
from the northern hemisphere.
And uh,
so she was finding
about a thousand variables in this one
object and it struck her that all of the
stars in the small Magellanic cloud,
we're roughly the same
distance from the earth,
so that it stars looked brighter
than they really were brighter.
And among the variables,
she made this very important discovery
that the brightest ones took the longest
time to cycle through their changes.
And so that meant if you saw one of
those stars and another part of the sky,
and it had the same
period as one of these,
but it looked a lot dimmer
than it was a lot farther away.
And that was the beginning of a distance
scale for measuring the universe.
And that too is still
in use today. And, um,
there there's a movement afoot,
a successful movement to change its name
from the period luminosity relation to
the Leavitt law.
Uh,
Harlow Shapley took over as director of
the observatory after Pickering died and
he used Ms Levitt stars to
determine the size of the Milky Way,
which was so gigantic that he assumed
that there were no other galaxies.
This was a big debate at
the time was the Milky Way,
the only one or was the milky
way one of many island universes.
And he felt when he realized the
extent of it, that it was the only one.
And he also figured out from,
from judging the distance to
all the globular clusters,
he could see that the sun and planets,
we're nowhere near the
center of the Milky Way.
And he just took a perverse
delight in that and,
and kind of showing how
unimportant we were. And,
uh, he said that man is
not such a big chicken.
We're, we're really peripheral
to the universe. Um,
Shapleigh was also very
interested in ants. He got, uh,
he noticed them while he was working
at Mount Wilson and he studied them
scientifically.
He wrote several papers that were
published about add behavior.
So I,
I wish he could have seen this cartoon
is a Charlie Hanken cartoon from the New
Yorker.
And since the caption doesn't show,
we could pretend it's one of
those contests that they do now.
Um,
but we don't have a lot of times,
so I'll just tell you what it says
of makes you feel small, doesn't die.
Um,
as Shapley argued that when Harvard
really needed was a program in graduate
level astronomy,
uh,
and he wanted to institute it
and he said if they'd had one,
they wouldn't have had to
import him from California.
They could have promoted
from within the ranks.
And because of the history of
women at the observatory, uh,
there was a third Eris
Lydia hinge men who, uh,
was a relative Mariah Mitchell,
and who set up a program to pay for
a young woman to come and work at the
observatory for a year and then go
on to have a job somewhere else.
And so when Shapley started
looking for graduate students,
the only fellowship support he had
were these fellowships for women.
So he recruited from the women's colleges
and all the early graduate students
were women. And the, um,
the smallest photo.
This,
this lady is a Cecilia Payne.
Later Cecilia Payne,
good Pushkin and she came to Harvard,
uh, from Cambridge, England. And uh,
partly she was attracted
by the ability to,
to think about a future
in astronomy in America,
which she knew it was going
to be impossible in England,
but also the plate collection that she
wanted to use the plates of the spectrum
for her own research. And, uh,
she was the first person to earn
a phd in astronomy at Harvard.
And in the course of
her doctoral research,
she was trying,
she showed that the,
the different categories that
had been set up by the spectra,
that what they really signified
was stellar temperature.
And then she was looking at the spectrum
to assess the relative abundance of
different chemicals.
And she came,
came up with strikingly high percentages
of hydrogen and it just looked very
odd.
It was not what anyone expected.
So her advisor Shapley and the reigning
authority on seller composition,
uh, told her not to make
too much of this, just say,
okay, these were my findings, but
it's probably a spurious result.
And that's what she said
in her dissertation.
But she had called the tension to this
interest in problem and that got other
people looking at it and it took only
four years for everyone to agree,
you know, it really is almost
all hydrogen and helium. So, uh,
that was her finding.
Uh,
so when some people have
heard about these women,
you often hear them referred to by
the derogatory term Pickering's Harem.
Um, but they, I want to stress,
they really were well treated,
well regarded. Uh, he
put them up for prizes.
They were members of the
American Astronomical Society.
They were even inducted as foreign
members of foreign astronomical societies.
Um, and they, they loved the
work they did. Nobody left.
People worked there for
30, 40, 50 years. Um,
and then they've, they've really, uh,
some of them achieved world
fame, especially Ms. Cannon. Um,
and shortly after she died,
she was featured in wonder woman comic
book as a real life wonder woman.
That's what this is.
Uh,
now she's in a current website
called rejected princesses.
And this is all about women
who are two awesome, awful,
or off beat to be
featured in a kid's movie.
Uh, this is a still from
the remade cosmos. Um,
did anybody see the original Cosmos
series with Carl Sagan? So he,
he was a tremendous
influence on me. And, um,
uh,
the original writers did the new series
and just used a Neil Tyson as the host.
But the new series contain
something the original didn't,
which was an episode about the Harvard
women called sisters of the Sun.
And so there's, and he can,
and at the light table,
and that's Henrietta Leavitt
standing at the back.
And this has had a huge effect.
There are young people who've seen this
now and there are two new plays that had
been written about the ladies and there's
a web series and production about them
called insignificant, which looks
like it's going to be really good. Um,
they've even made it to Lego land and you
could have a tee shirt with this image
on it. So, uh,
that's Miss Lovett with the magnifying
glass and Ms. Cannon with her stellar
classification. And, uh,
Dr. Payne with her,
uh,
primary constituents of the stars.
Uh,
this is a work by, uh,
a young artist from La.
My name is Leah Halloran and she
has been looking at the glass place.
There are half a million glass
plates at Harvard, so they are,
that's really the glass universe.
Uh, uh, and they have, um,
they cover a complete
century northern hemisphere,
southern hemisphere chart plates,
spectral plates,
and uh,
so she sees them as artworks and she's
reproducing some of them as works of art.
Uh,
and these are enormous pieces that are
about six feet square and they're going
to be in an exhibition next spring
called your body is a space that sees,
there's still wants to be done at Harvard.
So there's a digitization project going
on now for the plates that's funded by
national science foundation because the
full information content has never been
mined from these plates.
And all from the beginning when the,
um,
when they began accumulating
in the observatory, um,
people would come to Harvard just to be
able to use them and sometimes Pickering
would actually send the plates out to
people if he thought they were serious
about their work and they took that risk.
So when they're a digitized,
it will be a lot easier for
everybody to look at them.
And you won't have to worry about
breaking the fragile plates. Uh,
I didn't have any of,
you know,
there was a flood this year at Harvard
and the place that lovely wooden
building, um, the minute the
plates started accumulating,
Pickering started agitating for a brick
building, fireproof brick building,
which he got.
And that's where they are today.
They're still in the building that
was specifically built for them,
but nobody counted on a broken water main.
And about 60,000 of the plates
got submerged in muddy water,
but
along with the digitization equipment,
but everything has been
rebuilt and they are there.
They are growing again.
And there's also opportunity for people
who want to help digitize all the log
books.
So there's a Smithsonian,
crowdsourcing a platform.
People are people who are
doing it. Uh, so here they are,
uh,
just about everybody's in this picture.
Everybody I've mentioned
except for Ms [inaudible],
she had died by this time. Um,
but just, uh, just seems to me in the,
in the light of recent events and the
anti-science bias that maybe you don't
feel here at Google, but it's out
there and it's really terrifying.
Um,
so I feel,
I feel it behooves all of us to tell
true stories about science and maybe,
maybe especially about women in science
because there aren't that many examples
for young women. And, um, this
group was pretty terrific.
[inaudible] so,
uh, as, as my program, I will steal the
first question. Okay. And my question is,
this is a hundred years ago,
we have much bigger telescopes now
we have much more people working in
astronomy.
Are these plates still being used for
current research or is it more research?
They are, it is current big. They
call it time domain astronomy.
So things that are discovered now you can,
you can access a plate of that exact
part of the sky and look to see what was
there that and that,
that has proven instructive in many cases.
So from what you said, it
sounds like there's, um,
there's a few things that went into making
it possible to have this, uh, you know,
close to gender equality at
this moment in time. Right.
There was the economic force of
them being cheaper to hire. Uh,
there was the grants that were available
just to get a woman at that point in
time and maybe even just they didn't have
opportunities elsewhere to find other,
other work for, you know, very
intelligent women at that time.
And a lot of that started to change,
you know, around like 1940s or so.
Right.
So real computers came in,
electronic ones and, uh, other jobs
or women started to become available.
So do you know if this was, was there like
an upward or downward trend, you know,
uh,
was,
was this a moment in time or was astronomy
still an interesting area for women
after that?
With the strategy.
It's still an interesting area for women
or an area of equality,
I guess.
Um,
well not everybody considers
their opportunity an equal
opportunity at that time
because they were paid less, but it
still was a sensational opportunity.
And the fact that they worked at Harvard
and that people knew about it made it
possible for women to go and work at other
observatories where they were allowed
to make observations and
have opportunities I don't
think they would have had
without that situation.
So one of the other things that went
into it with Pickering's open mindedness
and,
and willing willingness to entrust
that kind of judgment work to,
to the women who worked
for him. Um, there are, uh,
I think astronomy is a field where,
where women have a lot of opportunities,
maybe not as many as they would like,
but, but it's, it's, it's pretty good.
And at Harvard now, about half the
astronomy graduate students are women. So,
so you mentioned you had done the original
spoke for this book about 20 years
ago.
Can you tell us about the process of how
you got into actually going after these
archives and developing this project?
Oh sure. Oh yeah. That's um, well
it was at the back of my mind.
Uh, but I had other things that
I worked on for a long time.
Um,
I always wondered would it be possible
to even write this book because there
were so many characters. I had
mentioned that. And so I, um,
I worried about it, but then, um,
the more I learned about them in,
in the early nineties,
there was a, um, there was
a special issue of mercury,
the magazine of the Astronomical Society
of the Pacific that was just devoted to
women astronomy,
women in astronomy and
told some of their stories.
And I thought, this is just terrific. I
can't, I can't believe nobody's done this.
And,
um,
then there was a book just about Henrietta
Leavitt called Miss Lovett stars by
George Johnson.
And I was,
it felt kind of bad for him because
she was the silent woman of the group.
She didn't write letters,
she didn't keep a diary.
And we even have pick a person
to write a biography. She,
she was just the toughest
one. Her, her discovery,
her work was probably
the most important thing,
but he was really stretching,
you know,
he wound up giving what her grades
had been at Radcliffe. And I,
I didn't, I didn't want to
be in that position, but,
um,
finally I convinced myself the story was
so good that I would just have to count
on being able to,
to find the material.
So I first started at the plate stacks.
So that's what they call the,
the huge library of half a million plates.
And just looking at them was so exciting,
uh,
the way they're written
on. So you, you, you,
there's always something
in a project that makes,
makes me understand what really went on.
And you know,
the curator will give you what one of
those little magnifying loops and you can
lean over a light table and look
into one of those plates and,
and see the depth of it. And,
uh, then I was really hooked.
Uh,
and then I learned
about the diaries and I,
I had confidence that I
would be able to do it.
So it meant it meant a lot of
being at Harvard because the,
uh,
the archive is open only five days a
week and only five hours on those five
days. So this, it was kind of,
I'd be there just before they
open and then I just, I'd be,
I didn't even go to the bathroom.
I mean, I've just, uh, because the,
the wealth of material, I mean,
not just the diaries, but the, uh,
the observatory correspondence,
everything was documented
from the 1870s they made,
they made a letter press
copy of every letter,
whether they were designing
a new telescope, uh,
ordering new ink, whatever they
were doing. It was documented.
So it was just so much
stuff to go through.
And then I had to realize that I wasn't
going to get through it all and I,
so that was difficult to just pick,
okay,
I'll read these years of the diaries,
I'll read this person's correspondence.
Um, and then I had,
fortunately I had a, uh,
a visiting professor, writer in residence
kind of position at Smith College.
And so then I was nearby and,
um,
and that made it possible to, and, um,
what else was it like,
um,
there was a lot of science that happened
because at the beginning of the story,
nobody,
nobody knew the constitution of the stars.
No body knew what made them shine,
how far away they were, was really the
only thing that was known was positioned.
So,
and by the end of the story,
almost everything was known
at least an outline. So,
uh, there was a lot to cover and
I had to learn a lot of astronomy.
Um, I mean, this has been the
thing I've written most about, but,
uh, it was, it was a stretch and I, uh,
had many days of saying whatever
made me think I could do this. Uh,
but, um, I'm really pleased with the way
it came out. Did you have a question?
Oh, I'm sorry. Did we know
there are very few people left
who, who knew the real people? Um,
but there are a couple,
uh, some of Cecilia pains,
graduate students are still alive.
Um,
and then if you're interested, the, uh,
the American Institute of Physics does
an interview series and so she's one of
the people who's been interviewed for
that series and there's even a little clip
you can hear her voice
when did this period.
And so a,
the big money infusion
started in 1886 and then,
so the women were there and
it went through World War II.
During World War II. They
all did more work. Um,
Mrs Shapley was working for the navy,
uh,
doing ballistics trajectories.
Uh,
there was a lot of ballistics
trajectory work. Um,
and then by the end of the war,
there were the machine
computers coming in. Um,
and, uh, the observatory had less money.
Um, but they kept it going till, uh,
till the 1950s when, uh, ms pain,
Dr. Payne,
uh,
became the first woman promoted to
a tenured professorship at Harvard.
Um,
and yeah,
I guess that was your question.
Yeah. Through the early 1950s.
Huge Fan. Thank you for
coming. Oh, thank you. Um,
I used to teach with longitude and,
um,
I had to walk my students
through localization, Yada, Yada,
and then ending up ultimately with the
solution as a clock, obviously. Um,
and I'm always impressed with your
ability to take technology and history and
put it in.
We're living on this unbroken chain of
technological innovation and getting
context on it,
but the highlight of that was
going to Greenwich and seeing the,
seeing the clocks, um, so that,
that kind of historical tourism was
really remarkable. Okay. Oh yeah.
[inaudible] graph to do that. Is there
an analogy for that? For this? Yeah,
I see you didn't see the plates.
It's just that simple.
Yeah.
Now and Eric Kapor that,
that place has been decommissioned
and the building that housed the Bruce
Telescope is a chapel and I'm
kind of curious to see that.
I don't know if I'll get there. Um, they
also had a station in South America,
which is no longer, it's no
longer Harvard. It's still,
it's still an astronomy
station, but, um, yeah,
like you don't have to go that far. You
could, you could just go to Cambridge,
Massachusetts.
Oh, that last question
is, um, what's next?
I don't have a next idea. And I, um,
I feel I'm not really
finished with the story, um,
that I,
I've never seen a life documented
the way Ms. Cannon is document.
I mean,
aside from the diaries,
there's every libretto
from every opera she had.
And she was a big opera
fan. She was deaf, but she,
she shouted enough hearing
that she loved music. And so,
um, uh, as I said,
I didn't get to read everything and I'm
kind of still in this story and I'm also
struck by how few people know about it.
So I,
I put together a committee of about 10
people who agreed to read the manuscript
as technical experts because I didn't
trust myself that I'd really gotten all
the facts straight. Um,
so one of them was a,
is a woman who's a full professor
of astronomy at Harvard now.
And she of course had
heard about this situation,
but she immediately got distracted
from her job as a technical reader.
And she said, I didn't realize
they were doing real science.
I always thought it was something
just cute or quite, you know, this is,
this is a completely different situation.
And she was,
cannon was getting,
she won many honorary degrees and awards
and she took one of her awards and
endowed a prize for a
young woman astronomer.
And this faculty member had been
put up for that prize and she said,
I don't want it. I don't want any
price. That's just for a woman.
So now knowing the history,
she had a different feeling about it.
So I, I think it's, I think this
is too important a story to,
in so many stories get forgotten.
I mean,
how can we remember everybody in history?
But this is a really good story.
And,
uh,
somebody else came up to me recently
who was a woman in 1981 Harvard graduate
who was one of the first in
the women's studies program.
Never heard of these women.
So,
so I, I don't know, I
think I want to go be
an advisor or,
or a Kibitzer to the people who were
doing the new plays and the web series.
I think that'd be fun.
I wanted to go back to longitude
if you don't mind. The first one,
it was the first one is
your books that I read. Um,
I have the illustrated version and I'll
never forget flipping through the plates
in the middle where there's a picture
of John Harrison's first chronometer,
which looks like a
space alien contraption.
And then you flip the page
and there's two and three,
which also looked like
space healing contraptions.
And then you flip the page
again and there's four,
which suddenly looks like a modern clock.
Yeah.
A question I came away from the book
was what happened to John Harrison in
between three and four that
led him suddenly come out
with something that looked
like it looked like something that
might be up there for us today.
Oh, it wasn't certain
if you remember it. Uh,
it took about 20 years.
That was one thing.
And uh, a couple of important things. Uh,
he had,
he got somebody to make him a pocket
watch just for his personal use and was
able to put in one of his innovations,
the temperature compensation and that
convinced him that it would be possible to
build something.
We had been making these very
large instruments because large,
same synonymous with accurate.
And when did you realize that it was
possible to make it accurate and small?
Then he was willing to sacrifice some of
the other parts and went back to an old
fashioned a escapement and put the
whole thing in a small package.
Okay.
So in the course of
your work on this book,
what were some of the things that
most surprised or delighted you?
Um, I think surprising was the
graduate education situation.
I hadn't realized that and I,
even when I,
I was at least a year, maybe two years
into the project before I thought,
well, the graduate
students are women. Um, uh,
so that was interesting.
Then I had,
I had one of those weird moments,
uh,
Priscilla Fairfield,
who was a Smith professor and got involved
in the Harvard work and she would go
there. She would spend the
whole summer working at Harvard.
So she was constantly corresponding with
Shapley about their projects together
and what was the next thing to do.
And she always wrote to him on Smith
College observatory stationary.
And one day she wrote to him while she
was working at home and she put her home
address and it was the building
I was living in at Smith College.
Not if it wasn't on the college campus,
it was just in the town.
And so, uh, that was a big surprise. Um,
uh,
what else? Um, uh, just the,
the acceptance of them because I had
heard the term Pickering's Harem and I had
heard, uh, all the flap about
how little they were paid.
So I wasn't expecting the kind
of recognition that they got,
you know, especially the, the foreign,
the Royal Astronomical Society.
No,
both Mrs. Fleming and Ms.
Cannon were foreign members.
That was remarkable. Um, and then the, um,
the collegial nature of astronomy,
I think it is always been an international
science because you have to have
people all over the place to,
to get hold of it.
Uh,
but Harvard really became a hub and people
would come from Europe and work there
for weeks, months at a time. Uh,
and then they were all
corresponding with each other.
And even during World War One,
Pickering was so reluctant to break off
relations with anybody in astronomy and
immediately at the end of the war,
and he couldn't wait to get in touch with
the German observers and how were they
doing and what had happened to
their observatories and how,
how it was drawn. Immersion really
rally and in all cooperate again.
So that those were all kinds of feel good,
feel good things.
It's a happy story for the most part.
Okay.
Any other questions? You Ready?
Alright. So that, thank you very
much.
Thank you.